but now let's get into that first story
man
from timcast.com pennsylvania court
strikes down mail-in voting law a u.s
district court in pennsylvania has
ended an extension to mail-in voting
provisions which drew criticism during
the 2020 elections
let me try and give you the the quick
version of this because boy is it a
doozy in 2019 republicans want to get
rid of something uh called like single
single what's the i can't even think of
the phrase
i'll put it this way republicans didn't
like the fact that in pennsylvania you
could go and press one button and vote
for all democrats so they said the
democrats get rid of that they said okay
we'll get rid of that if you give us
universal mail-in voting the republican
said we can't it violates the
constitution and they said well we'll do
it anyway we'll amend the constitution
give us universal mail in voting the
republicans said we agree 99
in the house 98 percent in this in the
pennsylvania senate of of all of the of
the members agreed on this and passed a
law in violation of the state
constitution now
in comes the primary elections incomes
congress and the presidential elections
and some republicans take notice hey
wait a minute how did they pass
universal mail-in voting when it's
actually in violation of the state's
constitution state constitution outright
says absentee voting is for these
specific reasons but what republicans
and democrats had worked to deal on was
universal mail-in voting so they went to
sue and the judge said you guys wait
until after the primary and after your
guy lost to try and challenge this law
you could have you could have challenged
this beforehand and there's an
interesting point to be made there but i
don't think it matters i think the
problem is the democrats got swindled
the republicans agreed to a deal they
never had the right to
promise the democrats in the first place
so now here we are it is a year and a
half or so a year and a few months later
and now a state court has said yes the
the constitution outright says here are
the specific reasons for absentee
ballots you cannot pass this law here's
the kicker
democrats republicans alike have agreed
on a a bill to amend the constitution to
make universal mail-in voting
constitutional it would require two
back-to-back sessions where they approve
this that's not possible to do in one
legislative session so what they decided
i guess was we'll approve the the
amendment which won't go into effect
until a second legislative hearing and a
referendum from the public
and then we'll just pass universal mail
in voting anyway
surprisingly i believe it was 11 of the
republicans who actually voted on that
law to for universal mail in voting were
involved in the lawsuit saying it was
unconstitutional so i gotta say the
republicans are kind of dicks in this
moment but i don't think that matters we
can smack talk to republicans all day
and night the law is unconstitutional
now here's where it gets crazy the
supreme court of pennsylvania is i
believe five
five judges three democrats two
republicans and so it is widely believed
that the democratic supreme court in
pennsylvania is going to just say nope
it's constitutional regardless of what
the constitution says and if they do
you're going to have a law on the books
as you do now which says you don't need
an excuse for mail-in voting and a
constitution that says you can only have
mail in voting for these reasons ladies
and gentlemen this country's imploding
anyway guys how are you doing so what's
that like eighth grade civics right the
rule of the courts are to interpret the
laws not to make them yeah and and it is
the judicial activism is the end of
checks and balances
so yeah it's a friday hey man i'd rather
you like what did i say before we went
on their worst country in the world
except for all the others yeah
what do you do if the judicial system
has become political
except that you are being ruled by
judges but i mean there's got to be some
sort of constitutional recourse to pull
him out of office i would have well
actually only if the legislative branch
asserts itself which it hasn't been
willing to do for the last hundred years
anyway right i mean we
we promulgate 28 pages of regulation for
every one page of laws we pass but they
can take your liberty or your property
for violation of a regulation therefore
it is tantamount to a law that means
that they've abdicated their
responsibility to legislate right and
why because it's more important to get
reelected
than it is to to do it's the the axiom
is there's two types of people so those
who want to be somebody and those who
want to do something and tragically the
be somebody's outnumbered that do some
things like ten to one yep and
tragically pardon me as a liberty guy
the best bulk of the do somethings
aren't on the right
i think true i think the simple way to
put it is the system is falling apart
it's quite simple if a judge
on party lines can say
we don't care whether this is
constitutional or not you can't you
can't do this this late right so
initially they told the republicans who
filed the lawsuit over it well it's too
bad you guys did it they were treating
the individuals in the lawsuit as a
party and not as individuals that's the
first problem the judge should not say
your guy lost and now you're suing it's
like my response would be like my guy
look that's somebody else that's not to
do with my election
in fact one of the guys suing i think
actually won his election
so the judge first comes out the gate
the judges in general are just like
we're partisans and we know it
now it goes to the next state court and
on the merits they say yo the
constitution of pennsylvania there's a
section on absentee voting it says here
are the specific reasons you can have an
absentee vote it's like you're out of
town on business you're in the military
you're you're medically indisposed or
whatever
but no excuse universal mail in voting
not allowed
so the court says okay you can't do it
now the democrats are coming out saying
we don't care we're gonna do it anyway
this is gonna go to the state supreme
court
and if they on party lines
uphold the law and say the laws allowed
regardless of the constitution you have
a court saying the constitution doesn't
matter at all we're going to do whatever
we want on party lines they've already
used a party-line vote in the first
place republicans are the ones who made
a bad deal don't you know they swindled
the democrats in the first place but
this means that a judge can can enact a
law which favors democrats which will
then result in your legislators who pass
the laws being basically put in place by
broken laws the system is a hodgepodge
of duct tape and bubble gum jammed
together to hold stuff together and
we're all looking at it and i got to be
honest it doesn't make sense
if this is if this if this moves forward
with democrats in the supreme court
being it's a state supreme court not the
federal saying no we're going to let
this law stand i'm just like yo you guys
don't have representative government
anymore you have appointed judges who
who uphold unconstitutional rules to
allow their buddies to get reelected no
one's no one's voting for like what's
the point at that point
well i guess a point could be that you
might have a bout of corruption and then
after that it gets back to normal and
they're no longer corrupt so just
because uh one time there's a bunch of
corruption doesn't mean that it's ruined
forever keep that in mind um
i don't know how power never voluntarily
relinquishes itself
it doesn't power it does not relinquish
itself i think in like these judges are
they're human so like they're morally
shattered if you get if you get
demoralized shattered mentally shattered
judges like you're gonna see also
there's a weird behavior the problem is
the judges and the legislators are
viewing every single person as a member
of a tribe big problem the judge
initially outright when the lawsuit
happened should have said
is it constitutional or not instead they
said who is the person who's filing the
suit ah a republican well you're you're
you're only trying to get points for the
republicans and i'm not so i say no to
you okay well that that's not law that's
just tribalism look man i've been
telling people
we are in some kind of civil war when a
judge issues a ruling and explicitly
states your guy already lost so you're
doing this for that reason it's like
that judge is not ruling on the merits
he's ruling on the tribe he's telling
one tribe you are not allowed
okay so what happens next
i mean now you have the democrats saying
this court is republican so they're
saying the exact same thing republicans
are right our tribe wins the next
court's going to be democrat democrat
wins there is no no judicial system at
that point
so welcome to america 2022 how you guys
doing well as far as i'm concerned this
is just more undermining of more
institutions and
from what i saw in 2020 there is no low
that we can possibly reach that will not
turn something partisan like the
judicial system is not intended to be
partisan in any way but they're turning
it into that which is going to be a huge
problem down the road and maybe they
don't see that as being the case because
they're very short-sighted but if you
can use it against the other party they
can obviously use it against you and yet
if there is an institution a
foundational institution that
has demonstrated that it seems to work
still
it's the judiciary usually right we got
the written house verdict followed by
the aubry verdict right right and and
and i was just watching both of them
going okay they murdered that dude and
this kid like watched the video like
i was impressed with his fire discipline
candidly well what dude got murdered
you're going to trick you're i'm going
to get triggered oh you're going to
trigger you're going to trigger me the
guy jogging in georgia wasn't jogging
might not should have been kicking
through the houses but yeah he was a
burglary suspect
you shot him the prosecutor called him a
burglary suspect the only reason the the
mcmichaels got convicted was because the
judge gave the instruction to the jury
that unless they had witnessed the the
potential crime taking place they had no
right to try and confront him and deadly
forces now they're never authorized for
the protection of property except ahmed
arbory grabbed the shotgun from the
mcmichael and fought him for it which is
dual possession which resulted in him
getting shot which is a good argument
and then they put the guy who filmed it
in prison for life
now from from that point you need to
start the whole armored army question is
why is the guy who filmed it going to
prison for life you start to unravel the
threat from there and you realize the
whole thing is a travesty of justice
wow
dude i'm so excited to be on this
podcast
i think it's going to get like smoked in
the first 15 minutes
well it's something i'm i'm not saying
that but you get my point
at least as the facts were distilled
from me i thought that the system the
the judiciary had gotten it right what
their job is is to is to call balls and
strikes
and and that kind of is
politically dangerous uh because of the
tribalism that you make reference to but
kind of the way i try to do it like
you know when my guy was in the white
house and i was in congress i had a duty
to say when i thought my guy was wrong
well so this the armed armory thing is
actually a really great point to what
we're talking about here and it's why i
think in many ways the republicans are
losing and probably will lose but i do
think there's a great uh potential for
national populist republican types
people who are who believe in america
not you know we have a big problem with
corporatists crony conservatives who are
just you know rhinos i guess they call
republicans in name only
the issue is when it comes to a story
like ahmed arbory
fox news is more than happy to come out
and just praise the ruling without
looking at the facts because they want
to earn some points for them from the
mainstream media it is said that there
are many republicans who care more about
the opinion of the new york times and
their own constituents
that is why i think the republican
establishment is being gutted and ripped
apart
uh the amendment case being another
example of this where many republicans
came out were like see this was a good
ruling and then we actually had a
self-defense expert andrew branca as
well as some other lawyers come on and
break down the case and we were like oh
wow that absolutely is not true but why
were so many conservatives willing to
come out and and defend that ruling
well i think it's because
people on the right are many of them
they they care more about the opinion
not just the republicans but individuals
care more about the opinion of the new
york times than their own constituents
so you'll end up very often with
republicans being you know demure and
backing down where democrats go for the
for the ultimate win sure right what
happens is republicans take control and
hold the line and democrats take control
and push the football
absolutely
you know and you know it's hard to lose
it's hard to lose ground on the
offensive
i want to give a good example to people
because one of the narratives from the
left and democrats is that republicans
don't play but play by the rules that
republicans are steamrolling and getting
whatever they want and democrats won't
fight back
democrats repeatedly call for gun
control republicans repeatedly call for
not gun control
we continually get gun control laws
where are the republicans to call for
repealing gun control you see right
democrats say we want to ban these
particular weapons the left then says no
one is coming for your guns waco
disproves that then you get republicans
saying we've already banned a bunch of
guns we'll stop here no no republicans
how about you act like lauren bowden or
margie taylor green and repeal the nfa
abolish the atf and start passing laws
to repeal unconstitutional gun bans yeah
absolutely the contrast is astounding
because you're absolutely correct that
there are a lot of republicans who care
more about what the new york times says
than their constituents it's also the
case that there are many republicans in
general among the constituency who care
about what the new york times says more
than any democrat cares about what fox
news says the left doesn't consume media
that's generally catered towards
right-wing markets and shape their
thinking based on that or determine
which opinions they're going to be
comfortable voicing in the workplace
based on that
yeah you know i'm still fairly
optimistic though because the uniparty
establishment is struggling
you know it's it's
well said right i mean so we've had one
president who was elected without a
party affiliation and we were talking i
think off air again
i i loathe political parties yeah and
and and there are lots of people in
washington who i won't name because i'd
like to make a living
um who are in the party they're in
because they analyzed the district or
the state where they were running and
and said this is the party i need to be
in right there they're they're amorphous
uh and that's exactly who will destroy
this great thing that's been bequeathed
to us that this this republic
so
you should if you won't divert from your
party
then you shouldn't be elected period
right number one and number two if
you'll ever take a vote to get reelected
then you should never be elected to
begin with thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time